في كل مونديال وفي كل استحقاق رياضي تعود
النغمه القديمه مواجهه بين الرجال والنساء
حول اولويات الرياضه لكن الواقعه بالارقام
نساء عربيات متابعنا المونديال اكثر من اي
وقت مضى ومع ذلك ان الرجال في مصر ما اغرب
سؤال سالته بخصوص كاس العالم متابع
[موسيقى]
ممكن تسهل يعني
مثلا في الماتش بتاع
اليابان والكوستاريكا
سالتني تفتكر ال- ال- الفريق العجر ده
اللي مش عارف يوصل للجون ده ممكن يكسب قلت
لها والله ربنا كبير
ههه هو اغرب سواقه كم هدف محتاج حتى نتاهل
للادوار النهائيه لكاس العالم بتقول لي
همم
بضيعوا اترككم والحاجات دي في كاس العالم
والوقت كدهوت تقول احنا كل اربع سنين
بنشوفه مره وحاجه بتمتع بها بعد الماتش ما
خلص مصر وبلجيكا بتسالني احنا هنقابل مين
في كاس العالم
[موسيقى]